the maesters tell us that aegon came to
westeros with fire and blood and
hammered six kingdoms into one
fire he undoubtedly brought as the kings
of the rock reach and iron islands
learned aegon's own son maegor the cruel
was killed by the very iron throne his
father had forged if you believe the
tales
if you don't then perhaps the cruel is
not a wise name for a king to earn
darren first of his name tried to finish
his ancestors work and bring dawn into
the fold
for his efforts he lost sixty thousand
men and his own life of eighteen years
during the great targaryen civil war
known as the dance of the dragons a king
and queen each vied for the throne
dividing their house and its dragons
against each other
by the war's end king's landing was
smashed cities raised and sacked never
to be rebuilt and dragons had faded from
this world
for centuries the kingsguard had been
the glory of the realm
aegon the conqueror had established the
order as his personal guardians after
uniting westeros with fire and blood
he knew that some of his subjects
wouldn't take to conquest and his
dragons were no use against knives in
the dark
no doubt surrounding himself with the
greatest knights in westeros made his
rule more palatable and less foreign as
well
everyone in his kingdom soon knew the
names and sung the songs of the
kingsguard i certainly did from earliest
days
there was one kingsguard i forgot the
bastard's name who swore an oath to his
dying targaryen king to crown his
daughter after him
the very night that king died this
kingsguard crowned the king's son
instead
when an old man on the small council
died to protest this honorable knight
opened his throat
bastard died in a very civil war he
started along with the old king's son
daughter and most of their dragons
and the kingsguard all that duty and
honour and not enough brains to figure
out which targaryen to give it to
twin brothers even ended up on opposite
sides died with tears on their cheeks as
they cut each other down
i suppose i should think that's tragic
but stupid men do stupid things every
day and nobody cries over them
as little more than a boy sir kristen
cole replaced the legendary sirium
redwine on the king's guard and soon
rose to lord commander
but knights only know one way to settle
disputes
when prince aegon's father died sir
kristen slit the throat of an advisor
who objected to aegon's ascension over
his aunt the anointed heir
his actions so pleased the new king
aegon second of his name that he
appointed sir christian as his hand in
the ensuing civil war called the dance
of dragons
neither sir christian nor the king nor
even the targaryen dragons would survive
it
the targaryen dynasty united the seven
kingdoms and lasted nearly three
centuries
it was a dynasty forged in fire sealed
in blood and destroyed by rebellion
the targaryens are blood of the dragon
descended from the nobility of ancient
valyria a once mighty empire in the east
when the cataclysmic doom laid waste of
valyria and its people the targaryens
survived having settled on the island
fortress of dragonstone years before
they remained there for a century
until the rise of aegon the
instead conqueror
attempting to reclaim the eastern lands
of his ancestors
aegon sailed west for the seven kingdoms
his sisters visenya and rhaenys at his
side
to keep the bloodlines pure aegon
continued the custom of his valyrian
ancestors and took both of his sisters
to wife
together
they came ashore on the eastern coast of
westeros
their blazon a dragon with three heads
representing aegon and his sister wives
their words
fire and blood
while their host was small in comparison
to the armies of westeros that awaited
them
aegon and his sisters had a secret
weapon
the last of the dragons
he conquered every kingdom save dawn
which eventually bowed to targaryen rule
a century later
he had the swords of his enemies melted
down by the fiery breath of his dragon
balerion the black dread and forged into
the iron throne
the capital city of king's landing was
built on the eastern coast where aegon
and his sisters first came ashore
and aegon ordered the construction of a
royal castle on its highest hill
the red keep
according to legend house targaryen
survived the doom of valyria thanks to
daynes the dreamer who foresaw the
calamity and convinced her father to
flee their homeland
it could be true
the targaryens were always a bit
more
12 years before the doom despite the
sneers of his rivals
aenar targaryen abandoned the capital
with his family
legends claimed that his daughter
foresaw the destruction of the city in a
dream
more likely aina met with some mishap at
court and chose exile over execution
he and house targaryen slinked away to a
dreary remote god forsaken island
forsaken
no longer
arts now lost to the world
we transformed a tiny outpost into
dragonstone a fortress fit for the last
dragon lords
then aynar's descendants settled into it
like a tomb for their lost homeland
until aegon
when he looked east
he saw the past
old tired
dead
but when he looked west
he saw the future
gold in the ground
gold in the fields and no dragons in the
sky but his
he and his sisters rhaenys and visenya
flew over the great continent ostensibly
visitors to a strange land
but when aegon returned
he ordered construction of a massive
table carved in the shape of westeros
with all the notable rivers and
mountains that they had seen
a personal map of the seven kingdoms
then ruled by seven squabbling families
house durrandon held the stormlands from
their seat at storm's end due south of
dragonstone
house horror of the iron islands had
also conquered and enslaved the
riverlands and ruled them from harrenhal
a monstrous castle rising on the shore
of the god's eye
how stark held the frozen wasteland of
the north the oldest largest and
emptiest of the kingdoms
house lannister held the westerlands the
wealthiest kingdom thanks to their gold
mines
house gardner held the reach the second
wealthiest kingdom thanks to their crops
house aaron held the veil
or rather the veil held them the
mountains were impossible except through
the bloody gate which had never been
taken
house martel held the deserts of dawn
probably because no one else wanted them
together the seven kingdoms made
westeros a realm that wasn't yet around
ruled by great families who didn't know
what greatness was
aegon would teach them
with dawn in the fold and the faith put
in its place
none in westeros were left to oppose my
family
so we started opposing each other in the
dance of dragons a targaryen princess
tried to steal her brother's throne
thanks to her stupidity most of our
dragons died
in its time the dragon pit was a marvel
of the world full-grown targaryen
dragons nested beneath its massive dome
and even on the darkest nights the walls
seemed to glow with the fire of the
great beasts inside
as had the site's previous occupant
the sept of remembrance when maegor the
crew blasted it with dragon fire during
morning prayers
the screams of the dying men echoed
through king's landing all day and a
pool of ash and smoke hung over the city
for a week
but as it dissipated so too did the
rebellion of the faith militant
the sept of remembrance faded from
memory and maegor decided to replace a
monument to the gods with a monument to
his family
the dragon pit
for more than a century the targaryens
housed their dragons in the dragon pit
but dragons are not horses to be stabled
or hounds to be candled with each
generation the dragons became
less
less massive
less swift
less long-lived
and less invulnerable
during the dance of dragons
two targaryen factions killed a handful
of their families dragons while fighting
each other
a frenzied mob even broke into the
dragonpit and slaughtered the five
dragons chained there
though the last managed to bring down
the roof of the great dome on its
assailants
the dragons never recovered their former
strength or numbers
perhaps their line had been too broken
or perhaps others intervene to break it
further
but the last dragon grew no larger than
a cat and its death earned aegon third
of his name the epithet
dragon bane
[Music]
you